hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
so the motive of benevolence
generally a good moment
bentham is really keen that when we
think in terms of benevolence we don't
just think in terms of
individual people or even groups that we
identify with
that we like whose views we take into
account
who we see is actually mattering and
that we think of the entire community
so we worry about the pleasures
and pains
for everybody partial could be you know
one's own group one's own
club one's own pick whatever you you
like
what's he talking about here what's why
is this a big issue shouldn't we if
we're looking out for our own group
necessarily produce the greatest amount
of utility
pleasure over pain
let's think about certain basic groups
think about families
is it a good thing for you
when you make decisions to think about
how it's going to affect your family
from a utilitarian perspective
i know all the rest of you probably
think that it is from other perspectives
but we're putting on our utilitarian
hands now
yes or no
good thing or or not to take advantage
of the members of your family how they
would feel how they would be affected
so should you do your homework or not
think about how it's going to affect
your mom and dad
your brother and sister
probably not much right but you never
know
um
should you
date this person who is really but is a
lot of fun for you to date
maybe think about how your your family
is affected everybody in your family
hates this person because they're a jerk
to them
maybe you should quit breaking you
should break up with them quit dating
them
that would be to be a good utilitarian
you know your family is like a little
community isn't it
should you go home on the weekends or go
out with your friends
you know how's your family gonna feel
about that i noticed too we just brought
in another
group because your friends are also
affected
you know if you have 20 friends and only
four family members
maybe the family members are being a
smaller community their desires their
pleasures and pains matter less
what do you think
what about marist college as a whole do
you feel any sort of sense of
responsibility
towards the marist college community
other students professors staff
administrators
or do they not really
enter into decision making
you know if you if you litter on campus
so it's a really small thing right
um
the peanut butter cups right you can
walk on eat peanut butter cup throw it
on there on the ground
that's causing people this pleasure does
it matter
yeah man there's a utilitarian
perspective
the amount of discomfort it would have
taken you to you know pick it up and go
to the waste paper basket the
inconvenience that would cause you is
not worth the amount of displeasure it's
causing everybody else
let's say we keep widening it if we get
past the marist college community what
are other communities you guys
feel
responsible for
do you feel that you're a member of uh
a municipality
does it matter for your town
what you do and how you behave or for
your country
country's pretty big right
are you making your country bigger
are you making your country a better
place or a worse place by your reactions
do you take that into that
or you know think about other things
um as a consumer
you know you're benefiting the companies
that you're buying the food from or the
farmers or whoever else you're buying it
from
the food choices that you make matter
in these respects
if you have a chance to buy it from some
local farmers is that a better thing to
do than buying it from a huge
corporation like
nabisco good question to ask
um
bentham thinks that any time that we
focus just on the needs desires
outcomes of pain and pleasure
for small groups
our choices may
coincide with with the
principle of utility they may produce
greater pleasure and pain overall for
the entire community but there's always
a risk that they won't
there's always a risk that what's good
for my family may be to say screw
everybody else
we're going to get what's good for us
and everybody else better watch it
because we're going to you know exploit
them
and do whatever we can or think about
the way in which we we behave as
consumers what is it that we want
usually the most
get a good deal right
well what makes a good deal
i'm willing about that at least one of
you is going to buy something today
probably online
and the rest of you are going to buy
something within the next month yeah um
like you said one is a good deal
based on like comparable prices
get it as cheaply as possible right why
because
then you have to spend less of your
money
you feel good you get the pleasure
that's coming from the thing
but there's a trade-off if somebody has
to sell it under price
then um that might cause some pain
or if the process itself is built on a
lot of pain and misery you know
think about these iphones right
why did apple get so much grief
over the last couple years
who made these iphones those are
american workers for the most part right
chinese and why does that matter does
chinese people just feel more pain
you just
go ahead and work traditionally
exactly
yeah the the working conditions were uh
in many ways inhumane you know they
don't follow the same sort of labor laws
that we do and this is part of the
product
you know so when i'm when i'm buying
this or when i'm enjoying this
in a certain way i'm enjoying what from
a larger perspective might be other
people's misery
it's a product of that the supply chain
matters
there's a lot of cases in which we
should think bentham says about what the
effects for the larger community are
even though we don't necessarily see
them or
you know run into them
even though we may never encounter them
we should think about what what their
what the impact is
so there's two things that are kind of
interesting to play out with this
two things that that have to do with
utilitarianism
so one
is are we the only creatures that feel
pleasure in pain
what other creatures feel pleasure and
pain you know
yeah
yeah i mean poke your dog in the ribs
and see what happens probably going to
bite you or growl why because he doesn't
like being poked in the ribs because it
hurts
give your dog a treat your dog is kind
of happy
dogs and cats we think about them
feeling pleasure and pain um
as we go further and further down the
scale
maybe pleasure and pain don't mean
exactly the same thing i'm not sure that
a bug feels pleasure or pain or even a
fish in the same way as a hired animal
does um
certainly they don't they don't feel a
psychological pleasure in pain like when
i yell at my dog because he did
something stupid or wrong
he actually feels bad like you know
goes off slings off for a while then
comes back all apologetic that's actual
pain on his part
bugs don't feel that
you know
if i yell at the bees they don't care
but then if i take a bee and i poke a
pin into it
it feels pain doesn't it
in some rudimentary way
the bacteria feel pleasure pain no
probably not i guess if we get down that
far
so now think about this
when we're making decisions
should we take into account not only the
entire human community
but the animal community as well that's
that's one of the arguments that peter
singer one of the major utilitarian
thinkers of our time has
has made he wrote a whole book called
animal liberation
he recently actually changed his
position who was saying we should all be
vegetarians
to questioning that because if you look
at how crops are actually farmed
in you know
modern agriculture you have to kill an
awful lot of creatures in the fields
in order to to
produce wheat or
other you know soy or things like that
and he thinks that you had to take all
that into consideration um perhaps
that's going too far
i don't know where you stand on that
sort of thing we're going to be
utilitarians maybe we should restrict it
to human beings or hire animals
but it's hard to draw the line the other
thing that i'd like to draw your
attention to and um it's this effective
altruism chart that you see here this is
also coming from peter singer's
uh interesting ideas and his view is
that
if we're going to be altruistic
and we want to
get the most bang for our buck which is
a good utility good utilitarian notion
we want to accomplish the most good for
the most people
then we shouldn't let our emotions
drive our decision-making
why not
well you know think about
this you
you see
one person in need on the street and you
give to them in a kind of like he calls
knee jerk fashion
um is that going to solve the problem
that they're being faced with
why not
because it's not about the supply of
other people
yeah so you've got two important factors
there there's other people that are
being left out
and it's probably not going to be enough
i mean if you give the bomb enough for a
nice hot meal provided they don't spend
it on anything else
all they got is a hot meal they didn't
get off the street they didn't find a
job they didn't get housing or anything
like that and there's there's other
people in the same
case so his idea is that we should try
to back up a bit
and look at bigger and bigger
pictures and that's very much like what
we're talking about here looking at the
larger more expensive picture
and that will lead you to being able to
come up with better solutions so instead
of going with the heart immediately step
back use the head
and allow the head to come up with
longer lasting more systematic
approaches to to altruism that's all
coming out of utilitarianism
there's this this entire notion he gave
a ted talk recently on effective
altruism that this is drawn
you can see the
you know sort of image of it there it's
got this kind of pyramid you're only
helping out if you're starting with the
start you're only helping out this first
person as you step back you can help a
larger amount of people as you step even
further back you can help a larger